these masks are so awesome where do you
get up
hey Yuri I caught the bad guys but what
you might want to bring a ladder you
can't go past spider-man's best stories
without a good shoe allottee the
awkwardness of Peter Parker versus the
confidence of his alter ego the
relatable humanity of his adversaries
versus their heinous deeds and the
age-old diddly about juggling power and
responsibility insomniacs take on
spider-man juggles dualism - not just in
its narrative themes but in its
mechanical execution intense boss fights
are balanced with leisurely exploration
you'll make the most of Spidey's
acrobatic abilities in the open world
but also the mundane abilities of is
less super-powered allies in linear
stages dualities usually suggests that
there's a poorer trait but they're often
integral in characterizing the whole
that's insomniac spider-man in a
nutshell it's a fantastic experience
that completely absorbs you into its
unique slice of the Marvel Universe and
while that's partly defined by a slew of
menial tasks it becomes easy to forgive
because they're part of what helps
complete the fantasy of becoming a
friendly neighborhood spider-man hey MJ
what are you doing here it's obvious to
point out that a lot of the ideas in
Marvel's spider-man have already
appeared in a number of existing
videogame interpretations of the
character surely one of the pitfalls of
revisiting something so perennially
popular but we're insomniacs version
elevates itself and where it makes an
immediate impact is in this slick
presentation that neatly wraps major
parts of the experience it's obvious
that the last decade of Marvel Cinematic
Universe releases has had an effect here
the game's photorealistic slant shiz
away from any overt association to comic
books bright saturated colors and
stirring orchestral hooks are
ever-present and sweeping angles with
camera effects majestically framed
Spidey signature combat style and
acrobatics around the city emphasizing
them as the hyper real feats they are
but it's the story that has benefited
from Marvel's popular cinematic formula
the most insomniacs interpretation
spends a lot of time focusing on the
human side of the tail and Marvel's
spider-man features some solid
understated performances Peter Parker is
a veteran Spidey but still suitably
dorky and his relationships with the
important people in his life have a
major role to play the game spends ample
time dwelling on supporting characters a
move which aids later narrative
developments in producing more effective
impacts now there's always an
interesting dynamic with superhero
stories because you'll likely be able to
accurately predict the fates of
characters you're familiar with but
going along for that ride regardless and
watching with bated interest to see how
things unfold this time around is where
the value lies Marvel's spider-man takes
inspiration from an amazing spider-man
story penned by Dan Slott who is
credited as a writer here
Pete's elderly onme works at a homeless
shelter run by Martin Lee an
entrepreneur with a selfless heart of
gold but also a more negative side
needless to say things get complicated
and worlds collide but insomniac takes
multiple heartbeat tours from the source
material Lee and other antagonists also
benefit from a generous amount of time
devoted to exploring their humanity both
through cutscenes as well as
environmental storytelling Marvel's
spider-man features segments where you
explore key locations as Peter Parker
observing spaces finding audio logs
listening to Paige self narration
chatting with characters in playing
minigames passed off as scientific
research you'll also occasionally step
into the shoes of other characters like
mary jane a journalist for The Daily
Bugle in this timeline as she dives into
a more involved investigation using her
own unique set of skills mary jane
stages feature rudimentary stealth
mechanics on top of regular exploration
and her clandestine skill set becomes
more diverse as you continue to revisit
her side of story
these stealth mechanics aren't
particularly demanding and you don't use
them enough to wear out their welcome
but these supporting segments do feature
some memorably tense scenarios and as a
whole do help create a stronger
attachment to characters it's easy to
find yourself feeling more involved
be here turn it off flex now all this
narrative build-up pays off in a big way
- and when the game does reach its
tipping point it's shocking how
devastating the events can feel even if
you can predict what's coming Marvel's
spider-man is very good at making its
stakes feel sky-high evil actions
genuinely villainous and consequences
actually upsetting the story is
emotionally charged and effective at
spurring you into action later in the
game there's an urgency that builds up
it succeeds in creating the super heroes
dilemma of being pulled in multiple
places at once
each option a dire situation and the
circumstances make you feel helpless
despite your supernatural abilities it's
an incredible feeling and the major
beats of Spider Man story missions are
certainly one of the game's highlights
the high bar set in the main plot shines
a harsher light on the rest of the
game's activities there there are a
number of side quests most of which
branch off the main story but these
don't have the same narrative energy as
the main through-line which makes them
much less compelling there are also a
number of optional activities all
abstence ibly moderate tests of skill
asking you to exercise your abilities
and combat traversal or stealth these
challenges can be unique but the
dressing on them can also be uninspired
making them strange at best like curing
avian flu and pigeons and menial at
worse like three different kinds of wave
based combat challenges look I mean
dealing with trivial matters are all
part of being a friendly neighborhood
spider-man of course and randomly
occurring crimes as well as two
different types of collectible hunting
activities that encourage you to explore
the city are the activities that kind of
best embody this idea despite becoming
repetitive but when tasks like backing
up computer data or relieving the city
steampipe pressure or catching pigeons
suddenly becomes Spidey's number one
life-or-death priority when there's some
pretty serious stuff going on in the
main story it's hard not to be a little
bewildered the best incentive to
complete these activities is tied to
progression each type of activity offers
its own unique tokens as a reward which
you use to purchase new suits gadget and
upgrades
you suit same old me oddly the most
exciting activities are the ones plainly
label as challenge missions these ones
ask you to push yourself in time trials
to break a series of benchmark records
for bonus tokens completing challenge
missions are surprisingly the most
motivating and rewarding of all the
activities even containing some special
surprises but the strangest part about
the games activities lies in the use of
a trite open-world mechanic and that's
tower reveals you begin the game with a
blank world map and it's necessary to
make time to traverse through each of
Manhattan's boroughs to find and
reactivate a number of towers in order
to uncover the map and pinpoint optional
activities there is some light narrative
justification for this
Spidy needs to get access to local
police radio fare info on crimes but it
doesn't address the puzzling nature of a
veteran spider-man not innately knowing
how to get around New York City however
for all the bewildering mundanity the
optional activities do provide some
welcome relief in pacing from the more
intense episodes of the main story in
fact the game will at times give spidey
and by extension you dedicated time for
breaks in between missions to clear your
head with some silly low stakes
activities and in the end despite their
obvious flaws optional activities are
undeniably irresistible to seek out and
complete purely because they act as a
good enough reason to get out there and
play with spider-man's sensational web
slinging mechanics swinging around New
York as spider-man is endlessly
fulfilling it's a relatively
straightforward system that isn't overly
demanding on inputs but the minor
adjustments and variables in terrain you
need to consider while in motion since
webs require tangible attach points as
well as the weighty feeling of Spidey
makes the process feel satisfying Lee
manual there's just enough effort
required to make you feel as if it's all
on you it's the fluid animations visual
effects and the controller Rumble which
all play a big part in selling the
intensity the speed and the giddiness of
fleeing yourself through the air spotty
transitions between different movement
techniques seamlessly in most cases and
there's also a slowdown mechanic that
assists in helping you make more
accurate and graceful traversal
decisions holding l2 will slow down time
to a crawl and let you manually aim as
if to point maneuver but also let you
initiate surprise attacks and enemies
will perform other tasks as well taking
a photo of an iconic New York City
Monument can
later challenge mid-swing for example
and then going about your day can give
you a wonderful feeling of competency
because it's such an involved task
swinging around is Spiderman's greatest
joy despite its simplicity every move
you connect feels like a small victory
and the pace is rhythmic enough that
putting in the effort to move elegantly
becomes an absorbing experience in
itself there's a similar gratification
to be had from spider-man's combat the
Arkham Asylum inspired crowd fighting
systems suitably characterizes Spidey's
acrobatic nature and like web-slinging
observing the enemies and environment to
find your next best move makes it a
satisfying puzzle it only takes a few
hits for Spidey to go down so picking
the right gadgets and powers for the job
using the right techniques for different
kinds of enemies being proactive and
using your skills to manage / warming
groups and working to earn buffs and
long combos by focusing on hitting your
attacks and dodges with perfect timing
keeps even relatively unchallenging
encounters interesting comet specific
challenges also encourage you to mix up
your technique but it's the fluid
transitions between attacks and the
appearance of a natural flow that again
sell the excitement Spidey's flashy
finishers and their over-the-top camera
movements work to add some pizzazz in
addition to being an excellent tool in
their own right though you'll see these
animations countless times throughout
the course of the game and they do start
to lose their impact this is also true
of the optional stealth mechanics which
while effective will often see you
watching the same self
takedown animations again and again if
he choose to go down that path what
helps curb the monotony of combat later
in the game are the stories boss battles
these fights are intensely chaotic
affairs featuring unique takedowns and
bombastic set pieces though the solution
to beating them doesn't take much to
figure out your opponent's attack
relentlessly meaning you'll have to
constantly stay on your toes moving and
dodging around while waiting for an
opening a dynamic which feels very true
to the character and goes a long way
into making these moments memorable
literally
- shortcomings don't detract from
insomniacs achievement in creating a
game that feels like an authentic
interpretation of a beloved creation the
feeling of embodying Spidey and using
his abilities is astonishing and the
time spent on exploring its major
characters helped make its story feel
heartfelt despite superior bombast there
have been open world spider-man games
before but none so riveting and full of
personality none that explore and do
justice to this many facets of the
universe insomniac has created a
superior spider-man experience that
leaves a lasting impression one that has
you longing for just one more swing
around New York City even after the
credits roll
[Music]
nice entrance solid eight out of ten
release him he worked with us
[Music]
Yuri explanation please